I feel like you could put Beau drop him
into anything and he's going to be like
he's going to do it they'd say they
clocked him into 40. it's all apocryphal
maybe but they say he ran a 4-1-2 they
say he has the fastest 40 in history and
he's 230 pounds I love the myth around
him too it's like you just he burst
it out of his mother's vagina just
did a perfect squat landed it
and just you know scored six but uh I
remember watching a doc on him like he
had he had a little bit of a mean streak
in him too he would would bully kids in
his neighborhood but just throwing like
uh like uh mandarins or whatever on the
ground he'd be like just pegging kids
just dominate I loved it like he was
just like yeah these kids dude and
we're just dominate I think most people
agree he's the greatest athlete ever and
pure athleticism pure athleticism he
could be a linebacker he could probably
get rebounds in basketball he's
boxing people out it's got a
cannon it's like quarterback yeah he
could have been quarterback he probably
would have played quarterback now if
when it's more like dual threat is more
emphasized he would have been he could
have been Mike Vick times two because